this is a king or stinging
brandon ain't so les schwab theo
the lot king lizard got the king getter
sting it for you
state fairs you about it you ain't about
it
gang bangs butt plugs
all right and this is recent in utah
okay yeah you talking yeah we were in
the usa
they don't give a [ __ ] about mass corona
nothing
so i love affair me too nothing man you
get that big old prehistoric turkey leg
yeah little funnel cake i love it man
the rides bunch of vomit [ __ ] i don't
like the rides
you don't i don't like really scary
30 in a row but you can't go on the damn
zipper yeah i'm in control over that i'm
not in control of that damn zipper
yeah you can't go on the [ __ ] ferris
wheel but you do 17 backflips
this is the one we went on that
everybody would vomit on oh gosh
i don't like the rides either though you
been on that theo
constant vomit dude oh god i vomited out
of every car
have you been on that one where the the
slingshot like they slingshot you up
what fear are you going to you talking
about six flags we're talking about
county fairs yeah we're talking about
neighborhood pull up
you know the rides are gas powered we're
talking yeah there's
no bungee jumping at the state fair
brother gravitron used to get on that
and the guy that had a guy on there
would show everybody his wiener while it
was going around you couldn't do
anything you were just like
look at this dick
back up the wall and then you got to the
bottom and you couldn't even look around
and see if anybody else saw his penis so
his face was
blue oh your face is just cause it's
like this yeah
so you got to the end and you're like oh
i guess i'm the only person that saw it
even though everybody saw it that's
aggressive it's sexual harassment yeah
but it was like as a group kind of it
was like
together yeah it was basically the lazy
susan of [ __ ] being visually molested
yeah really i don't know if they have
that right anymore though
the zipper the zipper or the or the one
where it
spins real fast oh the gravitron it was
called
do you see gravitron inside what it's
like inside of gravitron
we had a ride at uh elitch's in denver
called the rainbow
and it would kind of do the same thing
but then some poor kid here we go
no this is here we go get you covered
this shit's fun though and you can't you
try to move your arm it snaps it back
cause you're going so fast
oh gosh you can't even get a boner in
these things chappelle
well no it's very hard too but what you
could do is if you had a little date or
some girl you was interested in
you could try to set your hand on hers
yeah and she couldn't get it off
yeah once you what you're there you're
there
dog i mean look at this people are just
absolutely miserable and this is
diesel-powered
that's diesel there's always that one
guy who tries to lay the other way
opposite ah dummies some guy wants to
know who's there
they are who's the dj in the middle oh
perv
wait you really can't move at all oh my
god it's so fun
that's pervy johansen in the middle dude
you'll get sick
though you'll get what sick oh i thought
you said something else dude because
that guy by us was showing you what you
did too
the guy bus was showing pain back in the
day yeah that would make me puke
oh those are fun too yeah [ __ ] i get
houses man
well g up bro yeah dog take some [ __ ]
uh
drama yeah what it does right yeah have
half a red bull man or something
i can't i can't do it look at that rod
huh
damn that gravy on that [ __ ] burning
will get on that rod right there
oh yeah i'll ride that thing all night
what's that that's just ice cream
blueberries
the food there's nice too damn damn
she's scared
another thing i miss about the fair yes
the animal ariel
oh my favorite the goats you can grab
the goats whatever you want
oh yeah you could touch all kind of
animal texas texas has a really great
state fair
oh i've been to that one a lot of places
do man it's a nice place to walk around
the kids everybody's walking around
calabasas is a good one they do oh they
do for halloween they have like this
state fair halloween all the food trucks
come it's dope oh
i love a good food truck me too
young man state fair 69
king it yeah because why would you sting
them who doesn't like them
like why even if you don't like the
riots you can still do other [ __ ] yo you
ever gotten a flea market
i might have gets dicey i've been in
some shady places
flea market super shady really
brendan you're the kind of guy that
would go you're the kind of guy that
i feel like we'd go to a flea market and
like hate everything no i loved it
really
yeah i grew up in flea markets dog oh
really yeah
oh i didn't see that on your on the
tfatkey website bio
that's not mentioning your credits when
you come to the stage i know right yeah
you know this guy from his flea market
childhood
okay that sounds
made up dude no the flea market in
denver is lit bro
oh flea market brendan want me kind of a
little more
hoodie like there's just a bunch of
weird [ __ ] it's people are selling
whatever they want
oh they roll their vans up they're
selling trinkets out the back
there's funnel cakes i used to get a
looney tune shirt
it had crisscross on it you remember the
crisscross the
group it would be like bugs bunny and
tasmanian devil and they had the
clothes would be backwards hell yeah one
of the baseball cards
one of the biggest flea markets is at
the pasadena at the rose bowl every year
it's a good time one of the issues i
have with it is most of the stuff they
sell in everybody's selling it
yep come over here and they gotta uh
they'll have
[ __ ] yeah we got a um taxidermied
dorito or something and everybody will
have it yeah as soon as this man's got
it this man's got it well now but back
in the day everything was original yeah
more original stuff yeah
come over here and get this 2 000 bottle
caps six dollars
damn it's basically up it's basically
like a pawn shop yeah
but for everybody for everybody and it's
outside now i've gotten some
good asian trinkets out there i've
gotten some good asian woodwork
you'll see a lot of good chinese
woodwork out there did you haggle with
them
yeah yeah i'll haggle with them are you
good at haggling i like it
i feel like asian people haggling is
just them yelling at you
oh really yeah this guy this was a white
guy selling asian stuff so maybe he knew
like asian people that had died i feel
like you'd go to flea market and buy
fishing gear i well the closest thing i
went to is a
which is a swap meet and i did pomona
santana
or costa mesa and i always buy fishing
gear i'd buy
remote control car stuff and i would buy
um
you know survival knives yeah would you
open the back of it yeah like
fishing wire i mean fishing
brendan survival's important it is doug
it is you think
you think chin shouldn't survive no he
should they look a little
tiny string saw
who's dude look i'll support you for so
long
this shit's getting weird dude yeah i
told you yeah okay
this tiny string saw yeah like two
little rings and it's metal and you
would do like this
so it cuts the wood just
shout single dude get an axe
yeah right but it's inside the knife you
could attach it it was awesome
[Music]